So many of us are
using camera phones
and sometimes tablets to make
some pretty terrific pictures.
I made this one.
I was sauteing some
colorful peppers,
and when I put the
cover on, I saw
what I thought would be
a pretty beautiful image.
So of course, I quickly
grabbed my phone.
And that's what this
is about, isn't it--
the ability to
quickly take a picture
without a big deal using phone
cameras to quickly make images
when you see
something interesting,
or in this case, something
very beautiful, in my opinion.
So did my son, by
the way, who made
a whole series of photographs
of my amazing birthday party
with my family at
Per Se in New York.
The dishes were created
by Chef Jarrod Huth.
And so these pictures
are basically
portraits of each course, all
taken with his camera phone.
And by the way, I adjusted
the color later on,
before uploading all of
these for this tutorial.
And here when we're permitted
to take a look at the kitchen,
we see a place very much like
a laboratory, showing process
and equipment and people
doing their thing.
So camera phones do
have an important place
for a means of making very quick
portraits of various places
in the lab, of the
work, of the equipment.
You can think about taking the
picture and then cropping it,
for example, as I did here.
But for the most part, the
quality of the photograph
is not what we're
encouraging in this course.
If you remember,
we did a comparison
between two images of a Petri
dish, one with my phone camera
and one with a flatbed scanner
at a higher resolution.
Well here, is another difference
for example of the device
that we've seen before
with the phone camera
and with my digital camera.
And you'll see that the
information is just not
there in the phone camera,
because of the file size.
It's just too small.
But once again, I'm going
to say there is definitely
a place for these very quick
and impulsive images, which
you're seeing now for the use
of web designs, for example.
I was having a really great
time walking around this lab,
making a few images
which work better
with a little bit of
cropping, and in fact, were
used for the lab's website.
So there is a place for
this kind of photography.
But remember, the
quality is just not there
and is not good enough
for a journal article
and certainly not a cover.
It might well be someday.
The technology is constantly
changing with each iteration
of the phone.
So yes, it's a great
idea to practice
walking around your lab,
creating these portraits.
And certainly, it's
an interesting way
of getting you to see.
But in the end, you've
got to use your full frame
digital camera with
the best resolution.
Here's an example of where I
had absolutely no time at all
to make a picture
for what I knew was
going to be a grant submission.
So this is a pretty,
pretty fast image
that I made with my phone--
pretty awful, and part
of some equipment that was
necessary in the research.
Took the image,
straightened it out,
then cropped it
like crazy, knowing
that eventually the final image
was not going to be up close.
It was a figure on the
first page of a submission.
So I did crop it in.
It doesn't look
brilliant right now.
But in the next image, I
edited out certain pieces
and created a laser light,
which was all illustrative,
of course, not for real.
And so this is
what I finally did.
I inserted it in a figure
that we used for a page
in the summation.
This is the page that we
finally wound up with,
replacing this image.
The idea behind this is, showing
the two next to each other,
I hope you agree that the
image that I quickly made
on the right is more appealing.
And it is taking up
real estate on the page.
So why not make it into a
summary graphic as opposed
to putting every single thing
you could think of in a graphic
and make it unreadable.
This is a way of using
very, very fast-made images
in a submission.